comment peut-on commencer à vivre une
grande histoire d'amour
quand on sait qu'elle devra bientôt se
terminer si vous voulez que la vie soit
généreuse vous devez les mais maintenant
et de manière inconditionnelle
parce que tout peut disparaître d'un et
si c'est le cas alors combien de temps
peut-être jusqu'à noël
le procès aux nouvelles
[Musique]
je m'appelle steffi - steve tu es fier
partir
elle est partie avec tout type du ciri
je vais les rattraper je prends quelques
affaires
il paraît que dans le voyage l'important
c'est la destination suis en route pour
paris
le voyage est tellement beau qu'on en
oublie la destination on peut monter une
vache comme un cheval
[Musique]
je sais pas si c'est les choses que
j'aime ou celle que j'ai pas pu faire
que je regretterai le plus
[Musique]
oui
cbe
ce territoire je m'appelle steve je lui
retire les morceaux de verre des faits
[Musique]
il a un tatouage qu'est-ce que c'était à
tous et dieu tu es vraiment un sale con
petit moque de moi
c'est ton cancer non c'est la tequila
[Musique]